some people were nessing you being The
Bachelor they're saying he was just on
Bachelorette just on paradise what do
you say to those people who do question
you as the bachelor um you know I
haven't paid attention to it too much
but I'm not perfect and I also think
that you know it's so important to
really continue to grow and to community
to push yourself and I know through the
Bachelorette and through bachelor
paradise I've grown as a person and I've
really sort of came into my own so you
know I don't pay attention to it too
much because I'm just focused on finding
my wife and you know being here and
living in the moment um I want to feel
all the emotions too good the bad the
happy the sad I want to feel everything
I talk about the elephant in the room
that you know is there you're a virgin
what's gonna happen with fantasy suites
Colton I'm waiting for someone that has
the right heart I'm waiting for to be
madly in love with somebody so if that
happens by the time fantasy suites comes
around so be it so it's not about
waiting for marriage for you it's just
about waiting for that right person
yeah it's about finding finding the
person that's for me that's gonna you
know obviously share a very special
you